cinquième demande de mise en liberté
conditionnelle pour patrick henry
condamné en 1977 à perpétuité pour le
meurtre du petit philippe bertrand à
troyes dans l'aube
cette demande est examinée par une
nouvelle juridiction à caen reportage
patrick fournier de leur décision dépend
la remise en liberté de patrick henry
ces magistrats s'apprêtait à entendre
celui qui a déjà passé plus de 25 ans en
prison
près de la moitié de sa vie pour un
crime resté dans toutes les mémoires
la france a peur en cet hiver 76 la
france découvre celui que la presse
appelle le monstre l'homme qui a enlevé
six étrangler un enfant de trois ans
patrick henry
nart les enquêteurs le cynisme et
l'arrogance de l'accusé glace un an plus
tard la cour d'assises de l'aude procès
demeure prier mais surtout procès de la
peine de mort conduit par son avocat
robert badinter il lui vite la
guillotine
malgré la fureur populaire devenu
prisonnier modèle patrick henry demande
cette fois sa libération cette fois elle
est refusée
jacques toubon puis elisabeth guigou
n'ont pas voulu prendre le risque
politique de libérer un assassin
d'enfants
mais depuis le 1er janvier tout a changé
ce n'est plus le garde des sceaux qui
décide mais une juridiction régionale
introduite par la nouvelle loi sur la
présomption d'innocence face à patrick
henry et son avocat un président de juge
d'application des peines et le procureur
général une juridiction qui laisse un
peu d'espoir à la défense du condamné
si cette libération intervenue elle
choquera une somme d'argent
c'est inévitable mais ce choc aurait
lieu même dans 10 ans le jugement a été
mis en délibéré à 47 ans bardée de
diplômes d'informaticiens patrick henry
vous recommencer une nouvelle vie et se
faire oublier
pour son avocat il n'est plus une menace
pour la société
tout comme patrick henri philip morris
fut condamné à perpétuité après avoir vu
sa peine de mort commuée en 1981